that good yeah like as a person so maybe
that was why she was with him and you
know one last goodbye no man you can't
pick and choose you can't in it if she's
asking for it in the last nine months of
life so what I got to do with you you
know why I got to deal with you that is
but then you wouldn't you wouldn't miss
the whole package and then at the last
nine months she wants to [__] me but
then can I play Devil's Advocate what if
we can just say like this is just
physical right I know we're going to
talk about like intimacy and emotional
and tremendous if you let me if you're
letting me before these nine months you
do me do my thing
you got nine months going then but
you're not gonna let me do my thing so
it's like now it's different in it for
men for men it's just physical that's
where men can just sold you on though
well what what why are you shaking your
head for men it's it's like not
emotional it's just physical yeah women
can be exactly the same less women that
person I have been that person where I
have gone and done what I felt like I
needed to do and had no emotional
connection I just wanted to have that
one experience or why didn't you say by
and large though women are attach more
emotion to sex because we release a
hormone that men don't during sex yeah
so there's like a bonding hormone and
it's the more Partners you sleep with
the less you release that hormone so a
lot of times like when girls say that
it's like they they've had a lot of
Partners so they don't release the
hormone as much anymore yeah that's
probably where I'm at wow oh you didn't
know that that makes so much sense yeah
because particularly like very
I don't like have loads of sexual
partners so I'm really careful because I
know I can get emotionally attached so I
prefer to do it in a relationship or get
pissed off if I'm
in a situationship it's happening it's
not worked out so that makes so much
sense I didn't know that well and that's
why like
um
a lot of times they say a girl can't
fall in love unless she's had the best
sex of her life because it's like that's
how girls bond is like when they that
makes yeah when they orgasm yeah
um it's different about men on the other
hand they can't have sex with a hole in
the wall and they'll be fine
I feel like a lot of men though I mean
majority of men like I've asked this
question like if you ever slept with a
girl that you wouldn't be seen in public
with 100 all men have done that yeah 99
of men but that's kind of the problem
with the sexual Marketplace because
essentially like the small percentage of
men are sleeping with all the girls and
so then like girls think they're on that
level but they're not yeah because like
your level is what you can get to take
you out in public basically okay yeah
that's a fact
there's a lot of girls men wouldn't be
seen with that dude [__] oh can I say
that wait no you can't
has a lot of girls that men wouldn't be
seen with in public that they've had
sexual relations with yeah yeah yeah I
mean it's similar to when you have a
date you have a blind date and he turns
up and you're like oh dear I can't go
anywhere that I was planning on going
and now I need to hide so it's it works
both ways but maybe the sex doesn't
happen that's a bit different yeah
and you'll get a food and you're gonna
[__] off and not see that guys that guy
is suffering
this whole situation is kind of
unfortunate
because I think I've actually been that
person oh so there was like um I did
this like American Girl She was Cali
like light blue hair really into like
every sexual thing you could imagine was
this like left crazy liberals you can
identify as like a man but but it's
heterosexual but also he's a lesbian she
had it with the tags and we're messing
around and one of her her last guy was
like
when we hung out she really liked this
guy like she really cherished the
friendship and she tells me that yeah we
spent a night together and it was trash
like like the deal was trash but like
the the love between them like she
really cherishes this guy
um so yeah and I was there like I mean
you know
the provider you're fine or not
it's unfortunate I just think I find it
really bizarre that a woman or a man can
have sex with someone that they
I don't know not attracted to like that
or
they don't feel something for
I find that really bizarre well it's
it's because it's got to have there's
got to be connection if I've got no
connection with you there's no way it's
gonna work it's just right but we were
thinking from a woman's point of view
yeah so from from like the typical
woman's point of view like we're
thinking how on Earth could you have sex
with someone like guys will have sex
with girls they hate yeah yeah you know
it is though okay yeah I can't speak for
every guy but it's that
post you know I don't know what was yeah
exactly
listen I'm not gonna lie oh [__] I spoke
to like Amanda man that and I've asked
them like questions like that like have
you ever and then a lot of guys do is
after the mission complete yeah they're
like oh like I should have aborted this
Mission beforehand but you don't see
that reality until like only a very
disciplined and aware man and very like
yeah it's not the I'll feel that
majority can definitely sleep with
someone and not feel nothing for them
but I ain't here for a relationship
yeah I have a lot mates that say oh yeah
I slept with this girl but I don't fence
here I love I don't I don't like her and
I'm like what why did you slap me there
in the first place
like there is no way why'd she sleep
with her you know because most girls you
kind of know what a guy's after like a
lot of times girls we pretend we don't
know we kind of like act like because we
want the attention from the guy but we
know we know which guy's actually like
us which ones are just oh yeah we just
pretend doing sometimes and say no I
don't know yeah but yeah as a woman you
you already know you already know if
it's gonna be a prick or not yeah
straight away yeah but but it's crazy
though because a lot of times the same
girls will cry later and say men are
trash but how can you say men are trash
when you picked them yeah
everything don't cry now I don't agree
with that yeah
why not though because
men lie yeah
it's not personal no no no no I agree
good okay so people aren't clear
people aren't fully honest yeah right so
someone will tell you everything you
want to hear in order to get what they
want 100 right and then when they get
what they want they might think oh you
know what I like that I want that again
I'm gonna keep lying they're gonna get
that again
so now the female is sitting there
thinking oh this guy's amazing but it's
all based on a lie
I've I found more that get what girls
will do is the guy will be Broad and say
oh I'm looking you know he might not say
specifically what he's looking for but
if you say are you looking for a
relationship specifically like they they
usually tell you the truth yeah yes or
no like no they might say no and I don't
think they do I think there's a good 20
of people that lie no the right guys the
right guys the scumbag no I don't want
to say anything about a guy that doesn't
get a lot of girls will do I don't think
it's just that dog or a guy that's not
confident in himself we'll tell you what
you want to hear but a guy that knows
what he wants I'll tell you exactly nice
so you know what it is I feel like guys
because it's so easy a guy that knows
what he wants will just tell you
like the kind of guy I'm if I wasn't
with my girl knows this as well I don't
beat around the bush if I'm trying to
[__] a girl I'll just let you know
straight up listen I'm trying to hit
what are you saying and if it's not that
and to get that it's not just a random
girl either it's a girl that I would
have interacted with before obviously
you know